we turn our attention back to Tropical
Storm idalia unlike the devastation in
Maui the toxic disaster that was East
palestin in Ohio where Joe Biden was
completely Mia well President Biden
today amazingly got to a Podium
relatively quickly even to address the
ongoing storm unfortunately he shifted
the conversation as per usual to himself
again comparing and commiserating over
his own tragic kitchen fire the kitchen
fire lasted a whopping 20 minutes before
the fire department extinguished what
they refer to as a minor incident he
nearly lost his precious 67 Corvette his
cat and his wife now for over a year
Biden has pretty heartlessly compared
almost every major disaster to what is
an insignificant kitchen fire that
almost destroyed his precious little cat
and Corvette take a look I didn't
anything like that but I lightning
struck my house we had to be be out of
that house for about 7 months I was
repaired because so much damage was done
to the house and half the house almost
collapsed I don't want to compare
difficulties but we have a little sense
chill and I what it's like to lose a
home years ago now 15 years ago I was in
Washington doing Meet the Press it was a
sunny
Sunday lighting struck at home on a
little Lake that's outside of our home l
a big
pond and hid a wire and came up
underneath our home into the heating
duck the air conditioning D make a long
story
short I almost lost my
wife my 67
Corvette and my
cat I know from experience how much how
much anxiety and fear and concern there
are in the people we didn't lose our
whole home but lightning struck and we
lost an awful lot of it about 15 years
ago what empathy Joe Maui was so many
homes were wiped out many people will
never go back to their home ever they
may not afford to be able to rebuild Joe
and some people now in Florida their
lives are going to be upended for at
least another year at least if they can
afford to rebuild it's not always about
you Joe no one really cares about your
idiotic small kitchen fire in Delaware
that nearly where you nearly lost your
precious Corvette a decade ago nobody
really cares about that tonight on the
bright side Le Joe is finally talking
about a hurricane in real time I guess
that's progress but maybe it's just uh
convenient timing since a storm made
landfall on one of the few days Biden is
not on vacation this month take a look
did you guys realize that the initial
Hawaii Wildfire response was not that
good or is it just easier for people to
to get help from the White House when
the president is not on
vacation so the premise of your question
and the way you pose your question I
disagree just for the record uh so if
you talk to if you were to do your
reporting and speak to the governor of
Hawaii the Senators uh of Hawaii the
folks on the ground they would say that
the president reacted in record time
when it came to dealing with the
wildfires uh when it came to dealing and
making sure that they got everything
that they need on on the federal level
to deal with what was going on on the
ground let's not forget there were more
than 600 uh uh federal employees on the
ground already to assist uh with the
wildfires in Maui so your question is is
wrong it's flawed in many many ways and
I would I would uh I would advise you to
go speak to the governor and the local
and state officials in in uh in Hawaii
record time just a flat outly Biden took
two separate vacations before he finally
making his way to Maui according to Joe
it was important that he remained on
vacation because he would just get in
the way in Hawaii the only problem with
that phony excuse was there was nothing
in the way left in the way to get in
front of for almost two weeks before he
showed up and when asked about the
devastation the loss of life no comment
he said that not once but he said it
twice and by the way someone should
really put Karine Jean Pierre uh in in
her binder uh cuz almost now an entire
month after the Maui wildfires that
Devastation not exactly a kitchen fire
and we still have no idea how many
people lost their lives how is that
possible and as of now at least 115
people are confirmed dead but anywhere
between 350 and 1,000 people are still
missing how do we a month later not know
the exact numbers here how come the
emergency alert system wasn't AC
activated on the island how come an
environmental nutc case according to
reports withheld vital and necessary
water that firefighters bravely and
desperately needed for nearly 6 hours
how did that happen this is a gruesome
gruesome indication that the federal
response Joe Biden's response has been
totally inept and it's not the first
time because we saw a similar level of
incompetence in East Palestine in Ohio
remember Joe promised he would visit the
rustbell community it's over 6 months no
sign of Joe Biden plenty of vacation
time no sign of Joe how you feeling
about Joe in Ohio tonight now despite
the fairy tales about his administration
you know they're all for the working
class workingclass communities in the
midwest yeah middle class Joe Scranton
Joe would rather spend his time in a
luxurious mansion on Lake Tahoe uh or
sitting on his tired old ass on a beach
in Delaware a chair that's too busy too
heavy for him to even move in his
pathetic condition and speaking of
vacation guess who's planning another
trip to the beach despite the hurricane
on the east coast in Florida and the
hundreds of missing people in Maui and
other important duties that a normal US
president we'd be taking care of you
know like let's see uh the energy prices
that are going Skyhigh inflation still
out of control borders where we now have
confirmed uh that in fact people on the
terror watch list are Crossing into our
country don't worry your president's
head it right back to Delaware for
another long weekend of rest and
relaxation and no plans to call off as
fun in the sun take a look are you
making any contingency plans on your own
schedule um either with this Labor Day
with your own personal travels and also
for your international travels that are
coming up next week that are you going
to need to three Shuffle BS well I may I
just don't know yet now Joe while Joe's
at the beach on under his little
umbrella that chair by the way he has a
hard time moving it probably somebody
should help him well Florida Governor
Des santis he's been hard at work that's
what leaders do in times of Crisis they
show up they get to work natural
disasters don't take a break during your
holiday weekend and today on Twitter the
first lady of Florida Casey Dan santis
she posted this picture on Twitter it's
a fallen 100y old oak tree at the
governor's mansion where the first lady
of Florida and her children were at the
time
luckily thank God nobody was injured
from this fallen tree but the death toll
in Florida Georgia the Carolinas sadly
it's expected to rise I hope it doesn't
our prayers are with everyone in the
Southeast tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else